how was your meeting then with the crown
prince here in saudi arabia you were
with him we understand for about an hour
and 45 minutes did you discuss
increasing oil production was there any
progress on that
we discussed everything that you you
would expect so i raised
human rights as i'm as i'm sure you'd uh
you would expect but we also talked
about
uh
how what we can do to to stabilize uh
oil prices to to fight inflation to help
consumers to help people uh the the gas
pumps uh the the at the petrol pumps and
you know the a lot of agreement that it
is important to to to avoid inflation to
to avoid the damaging uh economic
consequences agreement that we need to
uh work together to
bring peace to ukraine i thanked uh the
saudis for what they're doing they were
they were
joined the the un resolution as you know
in in condemning what russia has done
and uh
both agreed that we need to see an end
to putin's war did he give you any cause
for optimism that saudi arabia might
increase oil production which would ease
things for people at home
yes i think there's certainly a an
understanding that uh
there's a there's an interest
for
saudi arabia for all of producing
exporting countries and making sure that
the global economy is not damaged by the
current spikes that we don't get the
kind of uh inflation that we saw in the
in the 1970s
and so it was a very productive
conversation just to be you said there
was an interest would that mean any kind
of decision to increase supply anything
i think you need to talk to the saudis
about that but i think those uh there
was a
an understanding of the of the
the need to ensure stability in global
oil markets and uh and gas markets and
uh the need to involve or to avoid
damaging uh price bikes and and and and
as a strong
global economy
a strong uk economy which we we've got
continuing with a strong uk economy is
very much in the interests of uh of the
old producing countries as well and just
finally you say you raised human rights
there were three more executions
announced by the saudi government today
while you were here on saudi arabian
soil
was that a difficult conversation what
did you say to him did you make your
displeasure known or was it a general
conversation can you tell the public i
always raise
human rights issues as british prime
ministers before me have uh have done
time after time i think it's
it's best if the the details of those
conversations are kept private they're
more effective that way uh but i i think
what you can also see is that uh i i
think that uh people who come to saudi
arabia would uh would testify this in
spite of uh
that news that you've uh
referred to today
things are changing uh in saudi arabia
uh we want to see them uh continue to
change and that's why we we see value in
engaging with saudi arabia and why we
see value in the partnership but without
just discussing specifics did you
express displeasure at what has been
happening specifically i i i expressed
the the long-standing view of the uk
government as you'd expect